PROFESSOR: Last time we talked
about op-amps and the fact
that they allowed us to
abstract away certain
components of a circuit and
sample particular voltages
from a circuit and then modify
those voltages as we would
like in an LTI fashion.
Today I'd like to talk to you
about some other interesting
things that fall out of the fact
that we're only dealing
with LTI systems.
In particular, Thevenin/Norton
equivalence and superposition.
Thevenin/Norton equivalence is
the idea that if you have a
very complex circuit, but it's
still a LTI circuit, you can
express it using
a linear curve.
And superposition is the idea
that because you're also
dealing with LTI components,
if you're trying to solve a
circuit, you can take the
individual contributions of
independent sources to that
circuit and sum them in order
to find out either the total
current flowing through a
particular component or the
total voltage drop across a
particular component.
At this point, I'll walk
you through both.
Thevenin/Norton equivalence is
an important concept in that
you may have a very complicated
circuit.
And you don't really want
to talk about the entire
complicated circuit.
You just want to sample the
voltage drop or current in a
very particular location.
Because we're dealing with LTI
systems we can actually
express that particular sample
as its relationship between I
and V and possibly whatever
resistive component is
associated with the voltage
drop across that sample.
We can solve for this curve by
looking at the location that
were sampling and finding
the open circuit voltage
associated with that position.
Or if we were to leave the two
terminals from where we are
sampling open, what is the
voltage drop across that
section of our circuit?
That's the point right here,
where the current flowing
through the system is 0.
And there's a given voltage
associated with it.
Likewise if we want to find the
other intercept, we can
close those two terminals by
running a wire across them and
then look at the current that
flows across that wire.
That's the close circuit
current.
The slope is going to tell us
about our resistance, if any.
If we're only dealing with a
voltage source or a current
source, then we're only
going to be dealing
with a straight line.
Once we've solved for these
values, we tend to express
them either as a Thevenin
equivalent circuit or a Norton
equivalent circuit.
And you can convert
between the two.
Let's walk through an example.
Here I've got a simple
circuit.
And I would like to find the
Thevenin equivalent of that
circuit, given that I'm sampling
from above this
resistor and below
this resistor.
The first thing that I'm
going to do is find the
open circuit voltage.
Or if I were sampling from this
point to this point, what
is the voltage drop across this
section of the circuit?
Well, I've got 36 Volts.
There's 12 Ohms of
resistance in the
section that I'm sampling.
And there's 6 Ohms of resistance
outside the section
that I'm sampling.
So 2/3 of my total voltage
drop across this voltage
divider is going to be accounted
for inside my
Thevenin equivalent circuit.
So my Thevenin equivalent
voltage is 24 Volts.
Now I want to go after the
short circuit current.
If I were to draw a wire from
this terminal to this
terminal, I'm curious what
this value would be.
As a consequence of connecting
these two terminals, these
resistors are going to be
completely bypassed.
We don't actually have to drop
any voltage or put any current
through these resistors because
there's actually an
infinitely easier way for
the current to go.
In this case, we're just going
to follow Ohm's law.
36 divided by 6 is 6 Amperes.
But because of the
directionality on this short
circuit current, current in this
system is going to flow
in this direction.
So are short circuit current is
actually negative 6 Amperes.
That just leaves Rth.
Once again we're going
to rely on Ohm's law.
If we divide our voltage
by our current--
you can't have a negative
resistance.
We're actually going to divide
by the negative of this.
We'll get out 4 Ohms.
Let's do it again, this time
with a slightly different
sample point and
find the Norton
equivalent of our circuit.
So if I'm only sampling across
the 9 Ohm resistor--
I personally still solve for
the Thevenin equivalent
voltage first because I
think it's easiest.
I'll just make note
of it over here.
The voltage drop across this
resistor is determined by the
fact that this is a simple
voltage divider.
The other resistors
in this circuit--
7, 2, 9 Ohms.
So the voltage drop across
this resistor is going to
represent half of the total
voltage in our circuit.
That's 18 Volts.
The short circuit current
associated with connecting
these two terminals is 36 Volts
divided by the sum of
these two resistors.
Once again we're going to end
up bypassing this resistor
entirely because, think about
it this way, if there was a
resistor across here with 0
resistance, all the current
would sink through it, or it
would represent the location
for which infinite current
would flow.
36 divided by 9 is 4.
And because we're following in
the opposite direction we're
going to say this is
negative 4 Amperes.
In this orientation, the Norton
equivalent amperage is
actually the negative
of this value.
You sometimes see the arrow
pointing downwards.
This preserves our property
of short circuit current.
If this was short circuited,
Isc would still
be negative 4 Amperes.
And our Vth--
if our Vth was the voltage drop
across these two points--
ha, I haven't solved
for Rth yet.
There are a few ways
to do this.
But I'm going to
use Vth and In.
18 over 4, we can reduce
it to 9 over 2.
And if I were to solve back
out for the voltage drop
across this resistor just as a
consequence of I Norton, I
would get 18 Volts, which is
also the Thevenin equivalent
voltage for this circuit.
That covers Thevenin/Norton
equivalence.
And we're going to talk about
superposition really quickly.
Superposition is yet another
circuit-solving strategy.
It falls out as a consequence
of only working with LTI
components.
And it means that in order to
solve for a given component
current or component voltage,
you can actually find it by
taking the linear combination
of every contribution as a
consequence of independent
sources.
What do I mean when
I say that?
Well, if you have a circuit
like this--
and you might recognize
it from the
NVCC lecture earlier--
you can actually express it as
a linear combination of just
the voltage source and just
the current source.
Note what when I remove the
current source, I end up with
no connection because if you
have 0 current flowing through
a system, it's the
same as if the
connection has been removed.
Note that when I remove the
voltage source, I no longer
have a voltage drop across
that connection, but I
maintain the connection.
If in this example I was
just looking for I1.
I1 would be the linear
combination of the
contribution of I1 in this
particular circuit plus I1 in
this particular circuit.
So this is the expression
that I'm looking for.
In the first circuit, I'm just
going to use V over IR --
or V equals IR --
and I'm going to have 3 Amperes
in this direction.
In this circuit I'm actually
going to have to
use a current divider.
Identify that I have five parts
total to distribute
among these two branches.
Identify that this side is going
to get the inverse of
this side's contribution to the
total parts, or this side
is going to get the proportion
of parts equivalent to this
side's contribution.
And vice versa.
That this side is the side
that I'm interested in.
And so 2/5 of the total current
flowing through this
current divider is going to
end up in this branch.
2/5 of 10 is 4.
It's in the opposite direction
of this current flow.
So I'm actually going to
contribute negative 4 Amperes
from this subcircuit.
This should match the results
from the NVCC lecture.
That's my super fast coverage
of superposition and also
Thevenin/Norton equivalence.
Next time we're going to start
a whole new module.